[Music]  hey guys my name is Alex and I get you  something drink  yeah tell me Alex  I hear rumor that the Tao family the  owners of this restaurant are involved  in drug smuggling how true is that no I  don't I don't know what you're talking  about sir you know what just give me a  water yeah I'll take a water too but uh  tell me something Alex do you guys have  fortune cookies yes sir because I got a  fortune for you but I don't need a  cookie you see after tonight the Tao  family operations are over for good your  lucky number is three because that's the  number of minutes it's going to take us  to smoke this place out  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  roll this  [Music]  yeah